[Musique]
bonjour rony brauman merci de répondre à
nos questions sur arte france 85 mille
décès après le 11 mai selon des
modélisations d'épidémiologistes
réaliste ou alarmistes comment on arrive
à ce chiffre
je ne peux pas vous dire comment on peut
arriver à ce chiffre parce que je n'ai
pas eu l'occasion de regarder les
hypothèses sur lesquelles se fonde cette
débile
cette modélisation mais à ce stade ce
que l'on peut dire c'est ou ce que l'on
peut rappeler plus tôt c'est que toute
modélisation se fonde sur un certain
nombre d'hypothèses qui sont toujours
elle même un peu des paris des hasards
fin qui sont relativement hasardeuse on
se souvient que dans le passé un grand
nombre de modélisation ont été plus
alarmiste que réaliste elles ont prévu
beaucoup plus de cas qu'il en est
réellement produit pour diverses raisons
alors je ne veux pas du tout jeter
l'opprobre sur une modélisation sur une
hausse celle-ci est peut-être très
sérieuse mais disons que a priori pour
se prononcer sur elle il faut voir les
hypothèses sur lesquelles se fonde par
exemple l'hypothèse qui a amené au
confinement c'était qu' il y avait à la
fois une très grande transmission dans
les écoles notamment les écoles de
jeunes élèves de jeunes enfants et
diamants une diffusion en ap
à l'échelle des territoires or ces deux
hypothèses n'ont pas été réellement
vérifié et c'est d'ailleurs la raison
pour laquelle on commence aujourd'hui à
s'interroger sur les vertus réelles du
conte fil blanc mais moi je n'ai pas à
ce stade encore d'opinion arrêtée
il constate que certains attribuent au
film en le soixante mille vies sauvées
d'autres considèrent que c'est tout à
fait marginale et que ce n'a pas
grandement amélioré les deux hypothèses
sont émises par des gens très sérieux
des gens très compétents mais il faut
bien reconnaître que la science n'est
pas l'omniscience et qu' il y à
discussion il y a des bases c'est tout à
fait légitime
on en est à 24 min 400 décès dûs
dix neuf en france est ce que ça vous
paraît juste sachant qu'on ne connaît
pas le nombre de morts à domicile selon
olivier vers on le saura je cite début
juin et outre-manche le financial times
a révélé qu'il y avait deux fois plus de
morts dus coronavirus que les bilans
officiels
oui c'est possible mais ça reste de
toute façon des mortalités quand même
relativement modéré il ya environ six
cent mille personnes qui meurent chaque
année est rappelons le vient que en
france donc ce qu'il faut considérer ce
sont les hausses de mortalité relative
c'est à dire combien de morts il y a en
plus de la mortalité habituel et cela ça
varie considérablement selon le lieu où
l'on regarde il est évident que dans le
grand est par exemple on a des
mortalités qui ont quatre à cinq fois
plus élevé que la mortalité habituelles
tandis que dans le sud ouest
la mortalité est à peu près étale et
même d'ailleurs il ya dans certains
endroits une sous mortalité peut être
lié au fait que les gens mènent une vie
plus saine l'ingénieux circuit loin
je n'en sais rien mais en tout cas il ya
des disparités très grande à l'échelle
territoriale et par ailleurs c'est
l'évolution de la mortalité qui est
important ce n'est pas la coupe c'est la
façon dont on compare les chiffres
mesurés disons chaque semaine ou chaque
quinze jours et je trouve que
l'avalanche quotidienne de chiffres que
nous subissons en france est tout à fait
trompeuses en est accablé par le
l'accumulation de ces chiffres qui
perdent finalement toute signification
il vaut mieux avoir trois ou quatre
chiffres que l'on voit dans la
révolution ou de l'art comparaison avec
d'autres chiffres plutôt que cette masse
de nombre qui sont finalement vidé de
sens qu'au moment où les entend
justement ce fameux chiffre 1 85 mille
morts après le confinant selon elle et
les modélisations dépit des meules
comment éviter d'arriver à ce chiffre de
85 mille morts est ce que selon vous le
déconfinement 11 mai est prématuré ou
pas non là je vais évidemment il ya
comme toutes les opinions sur cette
question il ya une grande part de paris
d'hypothèses de de spéculations moi mon
avis est que le déconfinement doit être
considéré comme un remède c'est à dire
doit être soupesée à la mesure des
risques et des bénéfices qu'ils
apportent les bénéfices ne semble tout
de même réel dans la mesure où les
objectifs du confinement était d'aplatir
la courbe des maladies aiguës de façon à
permettre aux services hospitaliers de
ne pas être débordé et de ce point de
vue là reconnaissons que ça a été une
réussite mais les inconvénients du
confinement se sont évidemment
l'effondrement économique le blocage
toutes les activités sociales et cela ça
un coup aussi ça un coup ils comprirent
un coup d'ordre sanitaire
ça provoque des souffrances des maladies
des morts et il faut donc peser les
conséquences néfastes du confinement au
regard des conséquences néfastes du cobp
ide et pas simplement considérer le
confinement comme une solution il
profite comme un problème dans cette
mesure là moi je pense que deux mois de
confinement
c'est probablement le maximum que l'on
peut supporter on est déjà pour beaucoup
de gens au delà du maximum
je considère que par ailleurs des
mesures barrières qui met un certain
temps à être intégré par la population
est appliquée de façon correcte c'est à
dire un niveau suffisant pour produire
leurs effets ces mesures barrières
commencent à être présente dans
l'ensemble de la population et que ce
sont ces mesures qui vont prendre le
relais du confinement mais c'est des
mesures qui vont vous permettre de
reprendre une certaine vie sociale une
certaine vie économique et je crois donc
que
en dépit de toutes les difficultés que
l'on constate des contradictions des
ratages qui demande des ajustements des
modifications comme vous l'avez montré
dans votre reportage précédente en dépit
de tout cela le déconfinement doit être
et la mesure à adopter avec évidemment
encore une fois le respect des mesures
barrières merci rony brauman d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes médecin et fondateur des
mécènes